In this lesson, we'll cover the End to
End Argument, as discussed in the paper, End to
End Arguments in System Design by Saltzer, Reed,
and Clark in 1981. In a nutshell, the End
to End Argument reads as follows. The function
in question can completely and correctly be implemented only
with the knowledge and application standing at the end
points of the communication system. Therefore, providing that questioned
function as a feature of the communication
system itself. Is not possible. Essentially, what
the argument says, is that the intelligence
required to implement a particular application on
the communication system, should be placed at
the endpoints, rather than in the middle
of the network. Commonly used examples of
the end-to-end argument include, error handling and
file transfer, encrypting end to end versus hop
by hop in the network, and the partition
of T C P and I P of
error handling, flow control, and congestion control. Sometimes the
end to end argument is summarized as, the
network should be dumb and minimal. And the
end points should be intelligent. Many people argue
that the end to end argument allowed the internet
to grow rapidly, because innovation took place at the edge in
applications and services, rather than in the middle of the network,
which can be hard to change sometimes. Let's look at one
example of the end to end argument. Error handling in file transfer.